安島暇なんやけど何したらいいと思う
うん
あんじめ見えませ今日は富士見社長ですいうわけで2020年ももう12月良いよ
終わりということなんですけどもみなさん今年1年どんな1年だったでしょうか
街が猫コロナの影響で家に居る時間自宅にいる時間が相当不利だと思うんですけども僕
の自粛期間中の人といえばもう
筋トレ化ゲーム化
アニメ今年はもう本当に家 new 時間がなかったからあ握る時間がすごいあったん
でえっ
こうアニメみましたはじめに僕アニメ大好きです結構あん見てるんですよこう見えて
よく見た目なんか用キャップ言ってるけど結構中身は良いんじゃなんで結構そのアニメ
とゲームとか色々入っちゃったいう行間のでですねほとんどインドアな人間だから自粛
期間中なんかそんな不自由な子を感じることねって結構有意義に時間を過ごすことが
てきたんですけどもそのなかでもアニメあえて今回の動画ではこの2020年後しに
放送されたアニメの中からあの僕の独断が偏見と見たことないアニメもあるしなんか
思い入れが強いアニメもあるからほんとね人に会ってはエースがないばとか思うことが
あるかもしれないんですけどもそれでもよしてください始めた長はエヌグ
2002準備
anime best 5いきたいとおもいます
すごい偉そうに総評させていただきますと2020年のアニメ
めっちゃ良かったですまんねーだろ見てる時間がなかったからかな本当になる今年の
アニメやべーだってくらい盛り上がってた気がします
というわけでぜひアニメが興味ないよって1万人目興味あるという人もぜひ見てって
ください
暗い go 雨
あのーとりあえず映画とかは nasne しました今年はもう映画といえばねぇ
放送されている普通のアニメのバックでと率トップ5決めて行きたいと思いますね結構
見てるんず1回考えたして
パットをお勧めしたいアニメって言われたら今13子出てきました今年分だけで猫じゃ
んマジで豊作だったです本当に大するいやに目が非常に多かったんですけども僕のこの
思考としてはあの結構あの恋愛モノが好きなんです
何所がイチャイチャしてるのとかめっちゃ好きなんでそういう偏りがちょっと起きるか
もしれません
あとちょっとダークな話も好きですつまりどれだしは結構その貿易
a というか可愛い女の子ソラ君が好きだった時期もあったんですけど最近音が大人び
てしまったせいかちょっとなく暗い話と拡大話してめちゃくちゃ中で話しかっていう
ものかといってるのが結構好きだったりしますねちょっとランキング
6 a
2ん
ています
ha
ちょっと人気の頃
酒をかな人気どころ避けますね呪術改善とか人間の消防隊とかもうみんな知ってるじゃ
ないですかちょっと a みんな知ってるみたいです抜くわね本当にねあー有名どころ
全部抜きました
いろいろ考慮してあるみんなに勧めたいアニメランキングベスト5にしますですねでは
頒布いたします
肇社長は1002020年のアニメ大
5位はへ
波よ聞いてくれというアニメでございます
俺個人的にめっちゃ好きだったんだけどなぁなぜ上のお話なんですけど女性の人が
ラジオパフまでて言ってやる仕事なんですよ見慣れちゃんって有効油ぞという題材が
まず珍しいですねなかなかラジオのアンディ面とか謎なお話してないと思うんですけど
も
なぜを題材にしているものを同アニメに落とし込むかっていうのですごいなんか見てと
いうを持つとかプレ北海道札幌勝負
第二主人公がひょんなことからラジオパーソナリティ生デビューし奮闘する姿を描くと
いうアニメでございます俺は結構好きでしたけどねぇね男女観っていうのあれこれが
あったりだとか
元彼がすげークソだったとかそういう話をついてラジオで言っちゃってなんかすごい
ことになっちゃうとか何か色々あって俺は
でしたけど結構たば大人抜けかな
バトル軽度からが好きな人はちょっとアレかもしんですけど結構視点ってるゲイナーに
ちょっと大人の方とかねすごいおすすめです
主人公と見慣れちゃってよたのかすごいトークが上手でして
見習いたいで室内で大要因です良いはこれはもう
ないいきましたねー
女騎士た覚えがあります2020年1月放送
そんなにと森の神様第8位でございます
そまには
よかったなぁ干支まあそもそもの話でも人間っていう人っていうのがもう絶滅に瀕して
てい系と呼ばれるそのモンスターみたいな人たちが住んでいる世界の話なんですけど
主人公とソマレちゃんっていうちっちゃい女の子が人間で人間でだけで迫害されるから
もうな金が入れないんですよねその場所でその染まりと森の神様っていうタイトルにも
ある通り
に漏れの神様っていうゴーレムなんですけどゴールってちょっと感情が薄いと言います
かロボットっぽいゴーレムっている人が染まるちゃんと出会って
なんか守らなきゃいけないなっていう本能が働いて
染まりちゃん守って旅をしていくっていうで旅の目的がその側にちゃんのお家を探す
っていう感じなんですけどすごい暖かい話ですねそれはちっちゃいんですけどほんと
すごいかわいくておりの神様
ゴーレムが本当に何か良い肝臓表に出さないんですけどもすごい様に
あんなことを大事にしてっていうかすごい感動するし心が温かくなるお話です
ちょっとあの思い出すだけでウルっときますしあのオープニングでんにんかまたいいん
ですよねなきたいって人は是非見てみてください続いて第3位
なんなら俺なんか今年感動するアニメねちょっと旬だった残せばて第3位書く仕事で
ございます真ん中の男の人の話なんです
けども娘がいいましてそのパパと娘の話っていうかお母さんがもういなくてパパを
すごく頑張ってるんですけど書いてる版がちょっとその逆というか小ネタというか娘が
学校に広まっちゃうとバカにされるような番号を書いてるからお父さんさんの漫画家の
仕事を娘に内緒にしてるんですよそれであの隠し事漫画を書く仕事と娘に泊
仕事をしているかかけ
さて隠し事っていうちょっとかかっているおしゃれなタイトルなんですけどこれも曲
家族の話ですねすごいあったかい話すんですけどチラッチラッとなく影のある要素が
含んでて対処につれてそれがどんどんわたっていくんですけど娘とお父さんそしてあの
いなくなってるお母さんのなんかすごい隠された関係だとこれ以上いません4本で記念
なんかのんびりしたコメディーチックなアニメなんですけど
も裏でそういう大事な話が進んでいくっていうんで二度美味しい味女でした後絵が
とてもキレイでした
家族が温かみというかほっこりする話でしたねー
俺今年癒し求めてるのかな目が癒される系の話が多いんですよねもっつん動画はどんな
人かダーウィンズゲームとか
異世界ものだからボイル曲振りとか今年特に好きだったらそういうのが癒される系だと
起動します続いて第2
彼女を借りします
好きでした木下和也くんという大学生の主人公がいるんですけども大学ねーさんの畏敬
木55で作っちゃった彼女様キャラ彼女がいるんですけどフラれちゃってめっちゃ
suke さんが振られてそう話し来てその寂しさを紛らわすがために連帯の彼女って
いうものに手を出してしまってそのレンジャーでした彼女がめっちゃ可愛すぎて
ちょっと好きになっちゃったよ
けど元が
彼のことが忘れられないよっていう切開主人公がポツっとフラフラしちゃってパソコ
図工
青い ek あ音がなっちゃうんですけどキャラかとってもかわいいのでそこはもう
待ってる大丈夫です4人がいるのか目のヒロインがまさに園に帰ったような男の子が
好きそうな話でした
レンターカー書っていうのを隊前にしてるか非常に良かったですね男の娘は好きです
今年俺はこれが結構好き
でしたねおすすめです
でははい r 1ですねちょっと変化系かもしれないけど俺は今年はこれが一番良かっ
たかな
運転に今年で一番好きだったのは第1
イエスタデイをうたってでございます
大学生大学生か大学卒業をした辺りの人たちにぜひ見てほしいなっていうアニメでした
ね
人口がとりあえずその大学卒業した後に長くをふら付いちゃってコンビニのバイト
ずっとしているフリーだっつっくな感じの生活をしているんですけどもそこに現れる
大学生の時なんか同期で仲良かったしなコツンって女の子が結構ません
てになって立派に働いているわけですねけど主人公ちょっと好きだだからそこに好評な
ふらつきつつももう一度行こう
若い女の方も出てくるんですよ主人公の音すごい好きなああああまたラブコメまぁ
ちょっとラブコメっぽいんですけどもなんか
世界観が好きでしたねアニメのタッチというか音楽とかがすごい優しくて世界に
入り込めた感じがありましたね
俺まぁなんか大学卒業して那珂市
ないことないなってこうなんかモヤモヤしてる中でこの先どう進んでいくのかちょっと
バイトしてるわけでいかないよっていうこの葛藤する主人公とその女の子2人との関係
とか年か結構現実味のやそんなモテないですけどねやっぱそういう話だで間にモテ
まくるんですけどもなんか我と現実にがあるというかすごい
なんか良かったですやっぱ先生の大学
同期の先生のしなぁこちゃんがすごい奥手で何もしてこないんですよ
王様はもう男女二人同じ部屋にいるんだったらなんかしてくれよみたいなさ
なんか ua みたいなあの子のを度か c 感じがすごいはの僕は楽しかったです
思春期を超えた男女の恋愛と人生な話でしたね
音楽も音楽と絵のタッチも含め僕はすごい好きな書
枚以上のこちらが僕が選ぶ今年のベスト5です誰だもう
王道というか発目さに人気ネッツかは結構羽生言ってるんで
もちろんほどここも人気なんですけどちょっとぜひとも観てほしいなっていう作品
こっちランでした今年はすごかったねもうあにゅ日暮らしをやってたしそうだと思い
まった支援への所定の日記
ブーツ回戦そして進撃の巨人の話です
すごいよなかな最近またコロナがやってきてるんで
外に出たい気持ちはわかるんですけどぜひ年末とかお時間ある時はアニメを観て過ごし
たいかがでしょうかこの子が本当おすすめですしお勧めの長年齢層とか3つを伝えたん
でぜひ自分がではまるなどをたら見てみてください
じゃん
[音楽]